Marie-Christine Morel vous êtes
biologiste professeur à Sorbonne
université et au Muséum National
d'Histoire Naturelle oui et votre grande
spécialité ce sont et bien les origines
de la vie et de l'archéobiologie
moléculaire attention j'ai réussi à le
dire alors nous allons essayer de
comprendre ce dont il est question déjà
et commencer peut-être par une petite
explication du titre de votre dernier
ouvrage
xénobiologie vers d'autres vies
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire alors Xeno ça
veut dire l'autre l'étranger
et la question qui se pose à partir
de
toute
identité humaine c'est évidemment le
rapport à l'autre qui sommes nous et à
partir du moment où on dit nous on dit
l'autre on désigne qu'il y a l'existence
de nutre et
l'autre ce sont absolument tous les les
organismes qui nous entourent qui vivent
avec nous sur terre et donc ce sont tous
des étrangers que ce soit des bactéries
que ce soit d'autres types de de
cellules des virus mais également ce
terme de xénobiologie donc ça renvoie à
une vie qui existe en nous et hors de
nous et avec qui nous nous nous
communiquons les liens que nous avons
avec tous ces autres qui sont différents
de nous mais le terme Xeno qui veut dire
aussi étranger renvoie à une une autre
forme de vie ailleurs dans l'univers
c'estàdire existe-t-il d'autres formes
de vie alors cela renvoie évidemment à
la définition de la vie quand onentend
qu'est-ce qu'on définit comme étant le
vivant puisque sur Terre on peut définir
quelques caractéristiques à partir de ce
que nous observons aujourd'hui mais
ailleurs on on a du mal à observer quand
même des des d'une part des molécules et
puis des êtres on ne connaît pas on ne
peut pas même pas conceptualiser ce qui
existe à la fois sur d'autres plan
planète et ailleurs dans notre galaxie
et ailleurs dans d'autres galaxies mais
on peut pas conceptualiser ce qui existe
ailleurs mais en revanche la vie elle
reste toujours la même ou est-ce qu'il
peut y avoir différentes formes de vie
mais il peut y avoir probablement alors
ça dépend ce que l'on met derrière le
mot vie mais il y a il y a certainement
peut-être oui peut-être d'autres
d'autres sujets d'autres plutôt que des
objets on va dire des d'autres sujets
qui s'expriment ailleurs et que les les
astrophysiciens nomme vie euh que le
biologiste on a du mal à nommer vie
parce que pour nous la vie c'est
réellement ce que nous observons sur la
planète Terre quoi c'est elle est
caractérisé la vie par toute une série
de de
propriétés que l'on peut rappeler ce
sont des essentiellement des
compartiments avec des au sein desquels
se se réalise des fonctions par exemple
la reproduction le le métabolisme les
échanges avec l'extérieur donc la vie on
la caractérise de cette manière là sur
terre ça ne veut pas dire que par
exemple les virus qui ne sont pas des
compartiments comme des bactéries ou
comme nos propres cellules ne sont pas
vivants mais disons qu'ils ont quand
même au niveau des molécules des
fonctions qui ressemblent à ce que nous
sommes capables de caractériser ceci dit
nous connaissons que 20 % du vivant sur
terre comment comment peut-on savoir
qu'on ne connaît que 20 % du vivant sur
terre qu'on sait quand même qu'il y a 80
% qu'on ne connaît pas comment on peut
savoir ce qu'on ignore c'est pas qu'on
ignore c'est-à-dire que vous savez
depuis quelques années il y a énormément
d'expéditions Tara océan pour ce qui ce
qui ce qui est parti de France et puis
d'autres expéditions qui vont ramasser
des quantités extraordinaires d'eau ou
de sédiments partout sur la planète et
qui ramèneent des choses en laboratoire
que nous ne pouvons pas identifier au
niveau du vivant connu il y a des
grandes bases de données mondiales donc
dès qu'on trouve une une fourmis ou une
fleur différente on séquence l'ADN de
cet organisme là et on envoie ce ce cet
ADN donc dans la base de données
mondiale et donc tout ce qui que l'on
trouve qui match comme on dit enfin qui
avec cette séquence de données on
l'attribue à cette espèce donc là les
les les les grands explorateurs ramènent
dans des laboratoires quantité de choses
qu'on ne peut pas assimiler à ce que
l'on a dans base de données et d'autre
part ce que l'on connaît répond à des
modèles qui sont très éprouvés hein qui
sont tout à fait qui sont applicable à
différentes espèces et euh ces modèles
nous montrent que tout ce que l'on
trouve et bien euh ne sont pas ne sont
pas ne rentrent pas dans ces modèles-là
donc on peut dire aujourd'hui
qu'effectivement on ne connaît que 20 %
et c'est la la grande majorité que 20 %
du vivant et qui reste 80 % de choses à
découvrir c'est-à-dire à caractériser
quoi oui qu'on a déjà découverte mais
qu'on s'est pas encore identifié quoi VO
voilà c'est ça alors commençons par
cartographier peut-être un peu la vie
sur Terre d'abord et ailleurs dites-vous
peut-être où sommes-nous d'où
venons-nous euh ou plutôt car il ne
s'agit pas de s'interroger sur l'origine
des espèces hein mais bien sur l'origine
de la vie euh d'où vient la vie d'où
vient la vie bonne question question que
je me pose depuis des dizaines d'années
alors c'est c'est une question qui est
très très difficile parce que comme je
viens de le dire euh les choses ne se
sont pas passées il y a 4 milliards
d'années ou 3,8 ou 85 milliards d'années
comme elle se passe aujourd'hui donc
d'où vient la vie la vie vient de cette
époque-là c'est-à-dire de milliards
d'années de 3,85 milliards d'années sur
une planète qui
était totalement différente de celle que
nous nous pratiquons si je peux dire
aujourd'hui c'estàd une planète très
agitée en formation avec des volcans des
éclairs des des de la tectonique des
plaques des tremblements de terre euh de
l'électricité en provenance des oruges
enfin donc toute une série de de
tourments qui agitaent la Terre
primitive et là sur cette Terre
primitive dans la roche profonde
peut-être ou bien en surface ou bien
dans l'eau 90 % de l'histoire de la vie
s'est passé dans l'eau quand même donc
c'est énorme 90 % donc on en est
vraiment sorti il y a pas très longtemps
et bien là dans dans dans cet
environnement des choses entre
guillemets se sont produit des atomes et
puis des molécules se sont formées qui
étaient en rapport avec l'environnement
de l'époque qui ont échangé avec cet
environnement et qui se sont adapté à
l'environnement pour acquérir des
propriétés pérennes c'est-à-dire ne pas
être balayé par le premier tremblement
de terre par le le premier météorite qui
tombaé sur cette planète et donc cette
cette périnie et ces échanges avec
l'environnement ont probablement mais là
c'est vraiment c'est complètement
hypothétique c'est à la lumière de ce
que nous connaissons aujourd'hui et bien
dans ce premier environnement et bien
les choses se sont peu à peu installées
et puis se sont éteintes très très
rapidement et d'autres choses sont
apparues dans un autre environnement 98
% des espèces qui sont apparues depuis
les origines ont n'existe plus
aujourd'huio donc on est vraiment tout
nouveau sur cette terre c'est donc
extrêmement ile de répondre à la
question d'où venons-nous mais vous vous
posez quand même la question ah mais je
me pose la question et je je ne cesserai
jamais de me la poser et tout le monde
se la pose je crois d'où je viens même
les enfants se posent c'est la première
question que se POS on a quand même des
éléments de réponse malgré tout enfin on
a des éléments dans ce que vous avveit
dit même sil y a des grandes zones
d'incertitudeou oui on a des éléments de
recherche c'est qu'il y a déjà une
interaction entre l'environnement
avez-vous dit et et puis c'est ces
réactions qui se passent vous savez nous
nous nous cherchons comme si nous
allions trouver et nous ne trouverons
jamais qu'en ayant toujours à chercher
c'est-à-dire c'est vraiment cette cette
maxime là je crois que c'est
Saint-Augustin qui qui disait ça et bien
je trouve que c'est c'est tout à fait la
la définition de notre de notre métier
de notre activité nous cherchons comme
si nous allions trouver parce que nous
avons une idée nous avons des hypothèses
mais c'est une quête inachevée et qui le
sera probablement pour toujours
c'està-dire nous ne pourrons J
reconstituer toute l'histoire du vivant
parce que justement la biologie et notre
discipline est une science historique
vous le savez certainement beaucoup
mieux que moi on ne peut pas refaire les
événements historiques tels qu'ils se
sont déroulés la biologie est une
science mais elle a cette particularité
d'être historique enfit par rapport à
d'autres sciences comme la physique ou
ou la chimie ou les mathématiques enfin
donc la biologie est vraiment à l'
interterface
entre c'est une science humaine au fond
même quand quand on s'intéresse à des
plantes ou quand on s'intéresse à des
des veres de terre ou à des bactéries la
science biologique est une science
humaine c'est-à-dire que nous nous la
regardons et nous l'observons et nous la
caractérisons avec nos yeux d'humains
chercheur alors il y a la vie sur terre
la naissance de la vie sur Terre et puis
il y a la vie de l'homme est-ce que elle
a une spécificité cette vie comment on
peut la décrire est-ce que c'est
différent oui l'être humain nous sommes
très très jeunes donc la vie est apparu
enfin que l'on on pense que la vie est
apparue aux alentours de 3,8 milliards
d'années on n'a pas de trace réelle on a
des hypothèses aux alentours de 2,7
milliards d'années on sait qu'il y a des
très très grands événements les premiers
organismes étaient sans oxygène jusqu'à
2 milliards d'années 2,4 milliards
d'années puis tout d'un coup il y a eu
ce qu'on appelle la catastrophe de de
l'oxygène c'est-à-dire que tout
l'oxygène qui était produit allait
oxyder le fer pour former de la rouille
enfin de de lhématite et tout ça et puis
à un moment donné tout était oxydé donc
de l'oxygène a commencé à remplir
l'atmosphère
et à ce moment-là les organismes qui
vivaient privés d'oxygène se sont
éteints peu à peu mais il y avait comme
toujours dans la l'évolution de la vie
des petits organismes qui vivotaient qui
n'arrivaient pas à s'exprimer vraiment à
profiter des échanges avec
l'environnement et qui grâce à la
présence d'oxygène sont devenus ce que
l'on appelle aérobie c'est-à-dire
capable de de vivre avec l'oxygène
l'oxygène qui était un déchet quelques
temps auparavant est devenu
indispensable à la vie donc à partir de
ce ces 2 milliards d'années euh et bien
tout a commencé à changer
euh il y a eu donc des des organismes
qui se sont qui étaient unicellulaires
qui se sont assemblés qui ont formé des
organismes pluricellulaires comme nous
nous sommes constitués de 30000
milliards de cellules nous sommes sommes
nombreux enfin nos cellules nous sommes
nombreux à l'intérieur de N nos cellules
sont nombreuses et en plus il y a nous
abritons des bactéries en plus nous
abritons des virus enfin bon on pourrait
parler de ça aussi aux alentours de dans
de 500 millions d'années c'est-à-dire 3
milliards d'années après la formation de
la vie aux alentour de 500 millions
d'années il y a des choses que l'on peut
caractériser des espèces de ver des
anélides et puis des petits insectes des
arthropodes enfin qui ont commencé à se
former et puis aux alentour de 300
millions d'années tout tout le monde est
sorti de l'eau enfin plusieurs
organismes sont sortis de l'eau et puis
aux alentours de 240 millions d'années
par exemple il y a eu les dinosaures
c'est c'estes organismes absolument
extraordinaires qui ont peuplé la Terre
jusqu'à 65 millions d'années autrement
dit ils sont bien plus évolués que nous
vous vous rendez compte ils ont vécu 180
millions d'années alors que nous nous
n'avons que 200000 ans d'existence on
est minuscule au regard de l'évolution
vis-à-vis de ces de ces organismeslà bon
voilà et puis sous les pattes des les
grosses pattes des dinosaures il y avait
des petits mammifères qui essayaient de
vivre de d'échanger avec l'environnement
mais c'était impossible avec ces grosses
pattes euh qui qui les écrasaient et
tout ça et puis lorsqu'il y a eu
l'extinction des dinosaures à 65
millions années euh dû à probablement le
un choc météoritique sur la terre qui a
empêché toute lumière de venir alimenter
la en quelque sorte la végétation et
bien
euh à l'occasion de l'extinction des
dinosaures bien les petits mammifères
qui végétai ont commencé à se à se
développer et puis à croître et embellir
c'était des mammifères qui après sont
devenus placentèes c'est-à-dire qu'il y
a eu un placenta qui s'est formé dans
ses premiers organismes et puis la
gestation est devenue interne
intrautérine et puis euh et puis voilà
et donc tous ces mammifères se sont
développés jusqu'à l'apparition des
primates
alors je déroule cette
histoire je déroule cette histoire parce
que vous m'avez demandé l'espèce humaine
mais l'espèce humaine elle est tellement
tardive qu'on est obligé deéresse même
plus non non c'est pas ça c'est qu'on
est obligé de de suivre un pe le CHEM
ouais bien sûr h si c'est c'est à grand
trait et donc c'est mammifère donc à un
moment donné sont apparus les primates
alors le premier un des premiers
primates était un un tout petit lémurien
euh vraiment tout petit un micro Cèbe
par exemple c'est tout petit c'est
minuscule ça mesure quelques centimètres
mais c'était quand même un primate après
ce premier primate après ce premier
lémurien il en existe quelques-uns
encore à Madagascar euh il y a des gens
qui qui essaient des expériment de
sauver cette espèce qui est en voie de
disparition et bien euh après ces
limuriens sont apparus les premiers
singes premiers singes à queue par
exemple leouis Titi qui a une longue
queue euh est apparue puis ensuite la
queue a disparu et ce furent d'autres
types de singes alors après il y a eu
les orangouttants et puis il y a eu euh
euh les gorill et puis il y a eu les
chimpanzés et puis il y a eu les Bonobo
enfin et cetera et puis tout d'un coup
est apparu euh une espèce
d'ominidée avec euh des
des australopythèques par exemple la
petite Luce était une
australopythèque et puis ensuite des
paranthropes et donc après les
australopythèques et bien il y a eu
toute la série des homos Abilis
sergaster et cetera les Néandertal là on
est dans une continuité mais pour autant
les autres espèces n'ont pas disparu
sont pas effacé au profil d'une autre ça
avec mon comant oui oui sauf que les
australopythèques ont disparu les
paranthropes ont disparu et puis les
Néanderthal ont disparu bien qu'ils
aient cohabité avec l'espèce humaine
puisque nous avons nous des gènes de
Néanderthal nous avons à peu près 2 à 3
% de gènes de Néandertal donc il y a eu
des croisements ils se sont ils se sont
rencontrés croisés et puis l'espèce
l'homo sapiens est une espèce invasive
euh sauvagement même invasive et donc
l'espèce humaine a exterminé les
Néandertaliens les Dénisoviens enfin
tous ces tous ces gens-là qui vivait sur
la même planète que nous pour aboutir
donc il y a à peu près 200000 ans mais
toutes ces dates là sont extrêmement
mouvante parce qu'on les paléontologues
et les les anthropologues font des
découvertes sans cesse sans cesse c'est
génial et donc voilà donc nous avons
200000 ans et euh et justement le
biologiste il fait quoi là-dedans est-ce
qu'il travaille avec le paléontologue
oui on essaie de travailler avec le
paléontologue on essaie de voir et bien
par
exemple nous sommes des animaux
exactement comme comme les singes comme
d'autres types d'animaux mais qu'est-ce
qui nous différencie de ces des singes
est-ce que nous sommes euh vous voyez
donc moi j'aime bien dire que nous
sommes des singes comme les autres parce
que souvent on a la question on a la la
question quand on fait des des des
conférences ou des rencontres qu'est-ce
qui n qu'est-ce qui nous différencie des
animaux mais je ma première réponse nous
n'avons aucune différence avec les
animaux parce que nous sommes des
animaux et pour autant nous ne sommes
pas des singes nous ne sommes pas des
singes parce
que nous marchons sur nos deux jambes
nous sommes des bipèdes et euh c'est la
bipédie obligatoire qui caractérise
vraiment l'homo sapiens et le fait que
notre locomotion se passe sur terre sur
nos deux pattes a permis à notre corps
de libérer les membres antérieurs et
donc à notre cerveau de prendre la la
main si je peux dire justement de
prendre les commandes de euh de nos
membres antérieurs nos membres
antérieurs qui sont devenus capables de
fabriquer des outils et des outils de
plus en plus perfectionnés donc
d'acquérir la technique qui est une des
caractéristiques de de
l'individuation humaine même si les
chimpanés font des outils ont des outils
en tout cas le tout le développement
technique et sociétal est propre à Homo
sapiens et puis euh cela a permis
évidemment la libération des des des
membres supérieurs cela a permis de
montrer et donc de commencer à à à
élaborer une communication et puis donc
à développer peu à peu le langage avec
notre cerveau qui est devenu comme on
dit monstrueux parce que par rapport au
au cerveau des des singes et à certaines
autres primates qui font entre 500 cm³
ou à à 800 cm³ le notre fait 1400 cm³
donc certains disent nous avons 900 cm³
cube de trop par rapport à euh la taille
d'un cerveau dans un
organisme animal et toujours en rapport
avec la taille de l'espèce et nous
évidemment nous avons une un cerveau qui
n'est pas en rapport avec notre taille
parce que nous avons la taille d'un d'un
singe enfin d'un singe d'un d'un Goris
enfin et et cependant notre cerveau est
bien plus important ce volume cérébral
est en rapport avec nos compétences
d'Homo sapiens la communication le
langage avant tout et euh tout ce que
l'on tout ce qui fait que Homo sapiens
c'est un un animal mais ce n'est pas un
animal comme les autres h ce qui ne veut
pas dire que c'est un un animal
supérieur et que il est au sommet de
l'évolution par voilà il est différent
il n'est pas au sommet de l'évolution
parce que l'évolution continue diff h
d'ailleurs on on le voit bien on observe
aujourd'hui avec l'intelligence
artificielle par exemple on observe bien
bien que des capacités techniques
nouvelles apparaissent qui qui vont
donner accès à autre chose qu'à toute la
technologie que l'on connaît aujourd'hui
et puis on fabrique aujourd'hui des
hybrides robot humains on
fabrique des ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui des des hommes
augmentés avec des prothèses avec des on
connait des cybords sur lequel le le
biologiste aura son mot à dire ou
comment du comment va continuer la re
est-ce que ça ouvre de nouveaux champs à
la recherche sur la question de la vie
est-ce que justement
l'hybridation neurobiologique
nanotechnologie on va dire constitue un
enjeu pour pour la biologie aujourd'hui
ou c'est-à-dire que ça ça constitue une
ouverture
extraordinaire si tantz que nous
renonçons enfin nous ou il j'en sais
rien parce que moi j'ai renoncé depuis
longtemps à être maître et possesseur de
la nature c'est-à-dire à vouloir diriger
l'évolution c'est-à-dire est-ce que
l'espèce humaine peut faire ce qu'a fait
la nature depuis 3,8 milliards d'années
est-ce que Nous C la bien compliqué
d'après tout le cheminement que vous
nous avez retracé céit donc c'est c'est
c'est absolument impossible ça n'est pas
on ne peut pas
et nous avons commencé notre entretien
avec la xénobiologie bien cette
discipline la xénobiologie avec la
biologie de synthèse est une discipline
relativement R qui a 5 à 10 ans de
d'existence qui est vraiment
extraordinaire parce que à la fois elle
est porteuse de de de découverte euh
majeure et puis d'une
ambition ce terme est est positif dans
dans ma bouche de découvrir et de
fabriquer euh tout un jeu des possibles
euh que nous ne connaissons pas
aujourd'hui alors ça nous renvoie à ces
80 % de vie que nous ne connaissons pas
parce qu'après tout dans ces 80 % que
nous ne sommes pas capables de
caractériser il y a peut-être des
organismes qui ne vivent pas comme nous
avec notre
compartimentation notre métabolisme
notre type de reproduction on n'en sait
rien on sa et donc la xénobiologie la
biologie de synthèse permet de mettre si
vous voulez des porte d'ouverture dans
ce monde inconnu et de découvrir en
fabriquant en laboratoire
d'autres types de de
d'organism des augmentés entre
guillemets de de fabriquer donc d'autres
d'autres mondes possibles et puis il y a
une autre ambition qui est celle la plus
euh plus plus compliqué à réaliser puis
même envisager c'est peut-on modifier
l'homme c'està-dire vous savez Jean ran
il parlait il avait il a écrit un livre
d'ailleurs qui s'appelle peutant
modifier l'homme c'estd l'espèce humaine
elle perfectible pe aujourd'hui certains
essaient de modifier le génome notre
propre génome c'est-à-dire notre ADN on
essaie de voir d'augmenter l'ADN vous
savez que l'ADN est basé sur quatre
briques atgc enfin pour les les les les
gens qui connaissent un petit peu et
bien des chercheurs essaient de
fabriquer de l'ADN à H lettres non plus
ces quatre bases là initiales qui nous
constituent mais donc euh on appelle ça
des achimojis Achi ce sont des Japonais
qui ont cette recherche Achi ça veut
dire h et mji mot donc euh et on s'est
aperçu enfin c ces chercheurs-là se sont
aperçus que ces ADN à 8 lettres on
pouvait les rentrer les faire
s'incorporer dans des cellules des
cherichiaacoli vous savez cette bactérie
qui nous qui qui peuple notre tube
digestif et que il cette bactérie était
capable d'adopter ces ces dn à H lettres
alors évidemment tout ça ne sort pas des
laboratoires puis même si ça sortait des
laboratoires ça ne peut pas vivre à
l'extérieur puisqu'il y a pas de il y a
pas de nutriment dans la nature qui qui
pourrait alimenter ces ces travaux mais
mais voilà donc voilà ce que fait
l'xénobiologie et la biologie de
synthèse et bien d'autres choses dont je
parle pas là mais c'est pour avoir une
idée vraiment de de cette force
d'imagination extraordinaire que que qui
se déploie en biologie et toujours en
rapport avec ave l'environnement mais je
parle beaucoup je mais là tout d'un
depuis tout à l'heure je pense aux
arbres parce que on parle beaucoup de de
de l'humain des animaux et on ne parle
pas de la végétation mais vous savez que
les arbres ont le comme nous nous devons
respecter la nature et nous devons
respecter les autres ceux qui sont en
nous et ceux qui sont hors de nous pour
pouvoir échanger parce que c'est ça la
définition de la vie ce sont les liens
que nous entretenons entre nous et avec
l'environnement h et bien les arbres
même allez dans une forêt et vraiment au
cœur de la forêt puis vous levez les les
yeux et vous verrez que vous voyez la
lumière autrement dit des arbres dans
une forêt ne se touchent pas ils
respectent ce que l'on appelle une fente
de timidité c'est très joli pour laisser
passer oui pour laisser forêt là voilà
et ben vous regardez allez-y vous verrez
c'est génial et donc pour laisser passer
la lumière de manière à ce que les
autres arbres bénéficient aussi de la
lumiè pour faire la photosynthèse donc
il y a dans la nature c'est dans la
nature non pas humaine mais dans la
nature même que de d'avoir un rapport à
l'autre et sans ce rapport à l'autre ce
lien que nous entretenons avec les
autres il n'y aurait pas de vie possible
sur terre c'est pour ça que chercher de
la vie ailleurs c'est d'abord chercher
le le l'environnement c'est caractériser
l'environnement et puis voir ensuite ce
qui peut se passer dans cet
environnement mais c'est illusoire et et
complètement
inutile de rechercher la même chose que
ce que nous connaissons oui ça
paraîtrait
miraculeux conditions ou c'est pas
miraculeux
c'est voilà complètement improbable et
même impensable je crois qu'il faut
penser les choses autrement il faut que
notre esprit arrive à accepter cette
cette notion de l'autre et de
l'environnement c'est comme ça qu'on
arrivera à trouver autre chose
merci beaucoup mariechristine Morel ça y
est
c'est av encore plein de chos ça passe
hyper vite ou merci beaucoup
mariechristine Morel ben merci à vous
merci à vous de votre attention